entre les mains de marie un extrait des
conclusions de l enquête de l'assistance
publique hôpitaux de paris
elle en a pris connaissance il ya
quelques minutes pourtant la lecture de
ces quelques pages ne lui a pas permis
de répondre à sa principale
interrogation qu'est ce qui vous dérange
des éléments de savoir pourquoi les mots
tu laisses un bond de savon éléments des
professionnels puis que ça n'a vu auprès
de familles retrouvent vous avez vous
vous dites nous si vous avez quelques
années je suis décidé ça fait mal
le saumon ne pas le nommer ne donne pas
plus de ravir la tête elle arrivée là
bas lui de soins pourquoi
car si le rapport reconnaît bien
plusieurs manquements relatif à
l'admission et à la prise en charge de
micheline myrtil il n'oublie pas de
faire mention du manque d'effectif du
service des urgences est ce qu'il le
reconnaît c'est ce qu'on veut le
sentiment qu'ils le reconnaissent dans
ce rapport de yabassi de pour la famille
l'espoir de réponses concrètes réside à
présent dans les résultats de l'autopsié
toujours attendu et à plus long terme
dans les suites donner à la plainte
qu'ils ont déposée pour homicide
involontaire